Let's revisit the string
to int conversion problem.
Remember that this invocation
should return an int value or
nil if the string can't be converted.
But of course, z is a plain old int.
It can't store nil.
That's why the compiler's complaining.
It's time to make an optional.
Z shouldn't be an int.
It should be an optional that can store
either of two things, an int or nil.
We change the data type of z,
and the compiler is happy.
Let's look at our other example, a
property that should be able to be nil.
Here's our simple
View Controller subclass, and
we want it to have a button property,
but it won't have a value right away.
The value will be assigned after it's
constructed, perhaps by Storyboard.
But the compiler won't accept it,
because this is not an optional,
it can't store nil.
So the class can't ever be created.
There's no button value
set in the constructor.
We need this property
to be a conditional, so
that its value can be nil
until it gets set up.
So we redeclare it with a question mark,
and the compiler is happy